La imagen debajo muestra
la gráfica de "y"como una función de "x".
Completa el enunciado
con base en la gráfica de la función.
Aquí tenemos la gráfica
y nos hacen algunas preguntas.
Este es el eje "y", el eje vertical
y este es el eje horizontal, el eje "x"
inicialmente cuando "x" crece, "y" "espacio",
vamos a ver esto
inicialmente, es decir al principio,
cuando empezamos con el eje "x" en 0
y el eje "x" va aumentando,
¿qué pasa con "y"?
Bueno, vemos que "y" disminuye o decrece,
entonces, inicialmente,
cuando "x" crece "y" decrece.
La pendiente de la gráfica, es igual a "espacio"
para toda "x", entre "x" igual a 0 y "x" igual a 3.
Entonces entre "x" igual a 0 y "x" igual a 3,
¿cuál es la pendiente?
Bueno, cada vez que nos movemos 1
en la dirección de "x",
nos movemos hacia abajo
en la dirección de "y",
nos movemos 1 negativo en el eje "y",
aumentamos 1 la dirección de "x"
y nos movemos 1 negativo en la dirección de "y"
así que nuestro cambio en "y",
sobre nuestro cambio en "x",
es la definición de pendiente.
Es en este caso nuestro cambio en "y" es 1 negativo
y nuestro cambio en "x" es 1,
la pendiente es -1 sobre 1,
esto es igual a -1 o 1 negativo.
Y lo vemos en la gráfica, cada vez que "x" aumenta en 1,
"y" disminuye en 1.
A partir de "x" igual a 3,
el valor de la función "y",
"espacio" cuando "x" crece.
Entonces, empezando en "x" igual a 3,
vemos que "y" crece o se incrementa
cuando "x" se incrementa,
mientras "x" se incrementa "y" se incrementa o crece,
así que "y" crece cuando "x" crece.
La pendiente de la gráfica es igual a "espacio" para
"x" entre 3 y 5,
para "x" entre 3 y 5, cuando "x" se incrementa en 1,
"y" se incrementa en 3
"y" se incrementa en 3,
si "x" se incrementa en 1.
Y como la pendiente es igual al cambio en "y" sobre el cambio en "x", aquí la pendiente es igual a 3.
El cambio en "y" es 3
y el cambio en "x" es 1.
Para "x" entre "x" igual a 0 y "x" igual a 4,
el valor de la función "y" es,
vamos a ver que hay aquí,
menor o igual que, mayor o igual que,
o igual a 0.
Así que para "x" entre 0 y 4,
el valor de la función "y" es menor...
es menor o igual a 0.
y por último aquí dice,
para "x" entre 4 y 8,
el valor de la función es...
bueno, vemos que "y"
es igual o mayor que 0.
Vamos a ver que no hayamos cometido ningún error,
vamos a verificar nuestras respuestas.
Ok, todo está bien.